especially with social media everybody's
comparing themselves to other people and
but even though those photos aren't even
real they're photoshop so you're
comparing yourself to like a fake robot
essentially walking back to glamour with
me Josh Smith and today we are joined by
the face of L'Oreal and she's so worth
it on fangirling so hard right I mean
babes we're bringing the pain I know I
know I'm always bringing it I love I
mean Josh pink is my everything I'm all
about making these boys wings now what
does being worth it mean to you and what
constitutes being worth it I think I
mean we are all worth it that's kind of
that's the we are is something that um
you struggle with everybody does I
definitely have especially in social
media everybody's comparing themselves
to other people and but even though
those photos aren't even real there are
no shops you're comparing yourself to
like a fake robot essentially really
interesting you touched upon earlier is
like we are living in a very almost like
anxious times as well because we're
living in this world of social media
yeah I think there's someone who's grown
up going through the entertainment
industry and in this context of social
media how has that shaped your
perception of yourself I went to a
regular school hmm so I you know I went
to high school junior high like
everything and kind of like social like
Instagram was just starting out yeah we
it wasn't I wasn't I can't think about
people like kids born right now we just
with the phone you know cuz I didn't I
didn't have a phone until later and
social media wasn't really thing but now
it's just so it's just growing so much
more but I um I feel like I was always I
try to really stay true to myself I was
the kid I would wear like like vintage
clothes just school and like kind of
wacky things and people would like make
fun of that and and think that was
strange but I was actually there the red
carpet in the fashion world
it embraces that in me yeah so I they
actually keep you would think it would
be like the other way around
be intimidating but the fashion will
actually embraced me and made me feel
confident wearing my crazy clothes so I
would be like you know what I would go
to school and I'd be like well you don't
know because you know well this is Grace
Coddington says you liked it or there's
a confidence in it in the fashion world
that made me feel okay to be true to
myself but it I don't know it is
difficult I think it's the most
important part of all of us that we have
to just be us but also be and be
accepted for us which that's the part
that's hard us I'm not that yeah but if
you were in the mirror looking in the
mirror and you want to remind yourself
that you were worth it yeah what's the
pep talk you would give yourself what
would be your worth it moves because I
feel like you've got a good have like
that bad yeah I think it would probably
be like a little this yeah a little
judge my favorite feature on my face is
my nose I love my nose so if I like I
can look in the mirror if I look at my
nose I'm like alright ready to go look
down the bar oh but what is the one
product that you pop on and you're like
I'm an empowered independent women
Destiny's Child so I think there's I
mean I have a bunch of really great
products that are all in my purse right
now but um lash Paradise mascara is like
my go-to mascara it's in a pink bottle
too also as a hair the shampoo and
conditioner and roses ever pure L'Oreal
Paris
and it's in a pink ball I know it's like
I can't get away from it I I'm attracted
to those products like their Peter be
they're very good and they're yeah
exactly
I'm they're walking feedback thanks I
mean I was looking a lot she's worth
their worth it weren't bad cuz you seem
like such an amazing ball of energy like
positive energy which I love but when
you have those down may men yeah how do
you remind yourself and how do you get
yourself out of those moments would you
say certainly hard you think all of you
get into that kind of that that whole
we're seeing so many images
all the time in our life like there's
just so much more content than you know
just like a breather
step outside like do some physical
activity and like I box so I kind of let
my yup aggression out in that way but
all they just like get off your phone
and don't make comparisons you know cuz
we all have those days where you're just
like feeling down a little bit about
yourself but and also I think it's
really important to kind of say
something that you love about yourself
because I think we're all kind of
embarrassed to just that it's gonna be
an embarrassing thing just say like to
be put on the spot alright there's
something earlier today where if someone
put me on the spot to say what are you
like what do you love about yourself
like oh my god
no should I say like that's so awkward
to say but we should be saying it
exactly that shouldn't be something
that's discouraged and I think there's
something in society that's like oh you
think you know I guess there's a
difference between vanity and confidence
a hundred percent yeah you're also so
lucky that you've worked and so many
incredible films were you paid very
empowering characters and very
far-reaching ones like Maleficent
beguiled like they're all such different
characters which one of those characters
who thinks taught you the most and
shaped you the most as a woman would you
say such a difficult answer I feel like
whatever the last role I did is the one
that made me grow the most because with
each part also I grew up in through
characters as well I was you know many
of many different ages I started so
young so I'm constantly was learning and
really growing as a young woman and
working with tons of female directors
that inspire me I don't know if I can
pick just one I mean I it's special well
if it's it is special because it's the
first sequel I've ever done yeah you
know the first time I did you know the
for when the first movie came out I it
came out when I was 16 but I filmed it
when I was 14 hmm so I was 14 like when
I created you know crazy character we
just you know we finished last moments
coming out soon and I'm 21 now yeah
getting to see a character grow that way
I've never never had to do that before
I've never really had to follow a
characters like trajectory create all
the space in between
be like who is she now and and what do
you want to represent to young people
now in that character who are who are
watching it especially young girls
because definitely after the first film
came out I started to young girls come
up really thinking out you're like
you're Aurora and this is like wow like
you owe you owe it to them to to create
a strong character that you're you know
that you would be proud of then wanting
to be like what's so amazing about you
as well from like observing your career
from a fire feels that you have a very
strong sense of your own voice which is
so incredible because I mean it's also
such a difficult thing to have from such
a young age how did you stay true to
your inner voice and are there times
where you've had to speak out and you're
like yes I feel more empowered from
doing that I didn't really have
necessarily a huge choice in what I got
to be in when I was really young because
you have to audition and you have to get
the part and if you can't you're like
yeah weirdly worked out that those
directors that I worked with and I was
so young were really incredible
directors like Sofia Coppola Alejandro
and Ritu like I got when I was so young
they picked me but I wasn't like you
know what I'm gonna do you know at seven
like I'm Alejandro dishes yeah being on
those film sets you also might have
learned what you want out of this career
and you want out of this passion and and
once you've gotten older and and can
sometimes pick my own stuff pasilla is
not it's I don't know I just I gravitate
towards certain things I think the
filmmakers are a big part of it you know
that are in the film you know the fellow
actors it's like if it's just someone
you really want to work with sometimes I
I just want to be in this to be around
them and exchange that but with
characters someone I want to be people
that are very different from myself and
I like high pressur pressured situation
so whatever is like the most challenging
or if I can just make myself feel very
uncomfortable and I feel like I'm I feel
comfortable in that space is what's the
time when you've found come to and
pushed yourself the hardest I mean I did
teen spirit which is a film where I
think
film which is amazing plus abuela oh
yeah maybe but that was doing those
performances we did live performances
and it was such a challenge I think it
was just such a challenge but overcoming
that fear of being on stage and
performing in front of you know extras
that are you know we're paying them to
yeah they had to plot yeah they're paid
to know but still just over it's very
singing it's very embarrassing
good or bad like it's just something
very vulnerable about singing like
there's nothing that you can hide behind
it's just you you hit the notes you
don't you feel the emotion like and it's
very just telling it's like a truth
serum like when someone sings you can
like oh you can kind of tell if they
have like a sensitive soul or I don't
know like you can just tell so I was
just scared that I was gonna be it was
gonna be like a fraud you know and just
working it working it at that I think
it's a scary feeling that you're like
maybe I'm not good enough to do this you
know but it was very that it was very
empowering after those performances like
feeling like you accomplished something
and like the adrenaline high is so
insane my god it's so I get how people
are like addicted to that like
performing on stage like that I've never
done stage work so we used to get you
out on tour yeah this might we need to
do I'll get the banner you find the
arena where make it happen great for
more amazing parent interviews with such
epic incredible women as alpha being
make sure you subscribe to the glamour
UK channels now have you done it I'm
going to